This presentation will discuss
the opportunities
for leveraging
Graphcore's IPU
architecture for
graph neural networks.
We will review
the computational
requirements and challenges of
graph networks
that require both
sparse access to memory,
a sparse computation,
and dense processing,
which is associated
with the use
of neural networks as function
approximators. We will then
introduce the intelligent
processing unit, the IPU,
and review the design
principles,
the processor architecture and
the system scale out.
Finally we will discuss
implementation
opportunities for
graph neural networks
on the IPO.
We will start by considering
graph neural
network processing
and its challenges.
Graph neural
networks have been
successfully applied
to a growing
number of
applications based on
graph structured data.
Applications that range from
the small graphs of molecular
chemistry and
drug discovery to
the very large graphs
of recommended
systems. This
application involved
tasks including node
classification,
link prediction,
and graph classification.
However, graph neural networks
come with a number
of challenges.
The first challenge is related
to sparse computation.
The implementation
of the graph
neural network is
based on the message
passing algorithm,
which is implemented
as a series
of message passing
steps or GNN layers.
And for each
individual message
passing step, the embedding of
a node is updated
using the neighbors
of the node. And for each of
the neighboring nodes,
the computation
involves the use
of a message
function to compute
a message associated
with the neighboring
node, and all the neighboring
node messages are
then aggregated
and sent to
an update function,
that produces the update,
the sequence to
update the embedding
of the node. And
both the message
function and
the update function
are parameterized by neural
networks and
therefore corresponds
to dense computation,
where there is
at the same time
irregularly
sparse connectivity
associated with
gathering the neighbours
of each individual node.
This GNN sparse connectivity
results in lower arithmetic
intensity and
higher communication
costs compared to
dense processing.
And these computations are
particularly challenging
for modern,
hardware accelerators.
Another challenge
is related to
heterogeneous graphs,
which are graphs with multiple
node types and multiple edge
types or relations.
For these graphs,
for each of the relation types
there is a different set of
neural network parameters,
in addition to
having different
set of neural
network parameters
for the individual
layers of the g n n,
for individual message passing
steps of the g n
n computation.
This, considering
that in general
in the order of thousands of
relation types for
this type of graphs,
this corresponds
to a significant
increase of the number of
parameters to train,
which can cause overfitting.
Another challenge of graph
networks is related
to the fact
that increasing the number of
GNN layers, and each each one
of these layers,
corresponded to an aggregation
of neighbors,
this causes an exponential
increase of multi
hop neighbors,
which causes an increase of
computational complexity and
memory cost.
At the same time increasing
the number of
neighbors aggregated
over several hops
and aggregating
information that
corresponds to
an increasing number of nodes
that are part of the graphs,
makes the representation of
the nodes more similar,
which causes over smoothing.
Oversmoothing can
correspond to
a degradation of
the task performance.
Another challenge
is related to
dynamic graphs.
Dynamic graphs
are prevalent in
real life systems
with applications
related to social networks,
forecasting,
epidemiology and others.
And these types
of dynamic graphs
evolve over time features of
their connectivity,
have for example additions or
deletions of nodes or edges,
and have the transformation of
the features of
nodes and edges.
An issue related to this type
of graphs is that
when collecting
a number of examples in a mini
batch for training,
especially when
the there is a large
mini batch,
the information
that is evolving
over time related to the last
samples in the batch lacks
inaccurate up to
date information
for the early examples
in the batch.
So there is a staleness not up
to date information that again
can correspond
to a degradation
of task performance.
A final issue
related to training
of graph neural
networks relates
to large scale deep learning.
We have already
described the issues
of deeper GNNs,
graph neural
networks that have
a large number of
message passing
steps which can
cause a neighborhood
explosion and oversmoothing.
Besides those problems when
training very large graphs,
there is the issue
that training
still requires efficient and
fine grained
access to memory.
And given the high level of
sparsity of large graphs,
when accessing a memory it is
possible that only a fraction
of the communication bandwidth
may correspond to
useful bandwidth.
We will now review the main
features of the intelligence
processing unit architecture.
The intelligence
processing unit
has been designed
from the ground
up to accelerate AI workloads
and to achieve
the following goals:
Fast and fixed cost
access to memory,
Efficient fine
grained computation
with low latency.
The possibility of efficiently
scaling to systems
that include
a significantly high number of
processors. And finally,
the possibility of maintaining
high performance
for low precision
compute, when using
low precision
number formats
that deliver high
computational efficiency,
for low power consumption,
and reduced memory cost.
This has resulted
in the following
main characteristics
of the IPU process:
A very large number
of independent
cores, and distributed
on chip SRAM.
Computation that is based on
multiple instruction multiple
data parallelism and relies on
a bulk synchronous parallel
programming model,
which allows to exchange data
between different
cores of the processor
without memory concurrencies.
And finally, in addition to
the provision delivered
by the hardware
of efficient computation for
fine grained
computational elements.
This is also supported
by the software
with the provision of sparse
instructions and libraries.
These slides give additional
details on the IPU
processor, the GC200.
A single processor
contains one
thousand four
hundred and seventy
two independent IPU tiles,
we distributed in
processor memory.
Each tile consists in other
words of both
compute and memory,
for a total of two
fifty teraflops
of fourteen point
six in compute
and one hundred
megabytes of in
processor memory.
The on chip memory
can be accessed
with a bandwidth
of forty seven
point five terabyte
per second.
Four IPU processors can be put
together to build an IPU M2000
machine which deliver a total
of one petaflops of floating
point six in
compute and a total
of three point
six gigabytes of
in processor memory.
The M2000 machine
also contains
an IPU gateway and
external DRAM,
for a total of
four forty eight
gigabytes of
streaming memory.
The connection
between the four
processors, the four
IPU processors
of the N2000
machine is provided
by FastIP Link,
that have a bandwidth of sixty
four gigabyte per second.
This slide compares the memory
subsystems of
the F2000 machine
with the memory subsystem of
alternative hardware
accelerators.
And the LPUM2000 have
a larger amount,
a significantly larger amount
of on chip memory,
which is accessed
with extremely
high memory
bandwidth in excess
of forty seven
terabytes per second,
and also have a much larger
amount of DRAM with
lower bandwidth,
which is motivated by the fact
that the large amount
of on chip RAM,
on chip SRAM
generally corresponds
to a reduced
requirement of DRAM
traffic.
This slide gives
typical examples
of the use of external memory
for training of
neural networks.
There is on the top the simple
case where the entire
model fits
on in processor
memory and there
is no need to access external
memory for training.
In other situations,
it's possible
to advantageously
store master weights
and optimized
states in external memory,
especially for situation
corresponding to pipeline
parallelism where,
there is only infrequent need
of the weight update
and accessing
external memory to
use the optimizer
state for updating
the parameters.
And finally, there is the case
where there is is
useful to have
a more regular
access to external
memory with phase execution
using streaming memory and
overlapping of
communication and IO.
And in this case,
the periodicity of accessing
the external DDR
is larger given
the provision of
a large amount
of on chip SRAM.
The IPM two thousand and seven
machine that we have just
described can be used to build
even larger systems.
The IPOPOD64 is constituted by
sixteen IPOM2000 machines
corresponding to
sixty four IPU
processors, and
provides a total
of sixteen petaflops
or fourteen
point six in compute,
corresponding to fifty seven
point six gigabytes
of importer
memory and around
seven terabyte
of streaming memory.
And these IPU pods can be also
used to build even
larger systems,
aggregating several racks,
several IPU pods,
to arrive to hundreds and even
thousands of processors up to
sixty four thousand
processors.
And these very
large systems are
glued together by
the IPU fabric,
which provides
connections between
the individual IPU processors
of each M2000 machine
within an IPU pod,
as you have described before,
and a connection to the host,
and connection
through the gateway
link between different racks
between different IPo pods of
a much larger system.
We'll now consider
the implementation
opportunities
offered by the IPU.
Implementation
opportunities for
graph processing
on the IPO are
given by the scalable and cost
effective DRAM
that can be used
to store large embedding,
but the possible use of large
SRAM to store neural network
weights and model data,
but the use of
distributed SRAM
rely on the BSP programming
model to deliver efficient
execution of it
for heterogeneous
computation and finally
the possibility
of using the fast
APU links for
efficient computation
in pipelines
or for phased execution.
The first method that can be
used to train
very large graphs
is based on mini
batch training
using sampling of nodes with
their respective
k hop neighbors.
Of course this method,
for deeper GNN,
for GNN with a large number of
GNN layers, can
face the problem
that we have
mentioned before,
related to
neighborhood explosion
and oversmoothing,
and in general
can cause a large
increase of
computational memory
overhead. This is
the reason why
the earlier
implementation used
the fixed neighborhood
size per layer,
reducing the number
of neighbors
segregated per each message
passing step, which of course
makes for effective
training of
very large graphs,
but has a downside
that corresponds
to a reduction of expressivity
of the model compared
to processing
on the original graph,
which may correspond
to reduced
performance, reduced
task performance.
Alternative
approaches have been
proposed more
recently decouple
the depth of the layer,
the number of message passing
steps with the number of hops
for neighborhood aggregation
with what is referred to as
shallow sampling.
This method can compromise
the computational
efficiency by an aggregating
an excessively high number of
neighbors with an increased
expressivity by
training deeper
networks.
The performance of mini batch
training can be improved by
sampling of connected
subgraphs,
which are provided by
graph clustering.
This method
improves performance
and also increases
the embedding
utilization of
PDMATCH training.
In this case the complexity
increases only
linearly instead
of exponentially
with the number
of GNN layers, which allows to
increase the number of massive
passive steps of having
the deeper GNNs,
which improve the expressivity
of the model and correspond to
improved task performance.
And the performance
can be further
improved by sampling multiple
connected clusters,
which reduces
the variance across
mini batches.
Both mini batch training are
based on selecting nodes with
the corresponding neighborhoods
and selecting
subgraphs provided
by graph clustering can be
efficiently implemented
on the IPU.
Both, in both cases
the mini batch,
the examples of the mini batch
can be stored on
on chip memory,
which provide
efficient and fine
grained execution with fast
access and for neighborhood
aggregation on chip.
The implementation
can be scaled
over a larger
number of processor
by parallel training,
in particular relying on data
parallelism and
pipeline parallelism.
With data parallel training,
the mini batch is distributed
over multiple processors and
using the on chip memory to
store the elements of the mini
batch allows to
continue to have
efficient training,
efficient access to memory,
but increasing the the size of
the mini batch and
speeding up training.
Pipeline parallelism
at the same
time involves
the implementation
of a number of pipeline stages
which can be implemented again
in the on chip
memory of a number
of IPUs. Different pipeline
stages can include
one or multiple
GNN layers, one or multiple
message passing steps,
that corresponds to the same
computation graph
with different
parameters. And
it's particularly
attractive to
consider the storing
the parameters of the message
passing steps on
the in processor
memory on the on chip SRAM to
reduce the amount
of communication
during training.
And both data parallelism and
pipeline parallelism
for speeding
up training can
be complemented
by the use of low precision
number formats,
which allow to store larger
batch sizes and
to be more memory
efficient and to store larger
amount of computation
element,
other larger number of samples
for node wide
sampling or larger
subgraphs in
the case of sampling
of the connected subgraphs.
And the lower precision number
format not only
allow to increase
the the size of the subgraphs
that can be added,
can be stored on on
chip, but also,
as we said before,
corresponds to more efficient
computation and reduced power
consumption.
As an example of efficient
computation on the IPO,
we consider now temporal
graph networks.
This is current work in
collaboration with Michael
Brosteyn and Emmanuel Rossi,
who had developed and proposed
the original temporal graph
network model.
Temporal graph
networks operate
on continuous time
dynamic graph
that are represented as series
of temporal events.
That corresponds
to the evolution
of features or
connections over time.
The temporal event,
as we said before,
for a dynamic graph can be can
be constituted by the addition
or deletion of a note
or the interaction
between pair of notes,
the modification of the edge
between between
different notes.
In the case of the model,
of the temporal graph
network model,
it's the characteristic
is that
the node, each
node is associated
with a memory, a state,
that is updated
after every event.
The computation starts by
collecting a mini
batch of a number
of recent temporal events for
processing and this mini batch
contains the current state of
the nodes involved in the in
the mini batch,
in the events that
we consider.
And this information is then
used to compute a message
associated with the the nodes
under consideration.
And the messages are then used
to update the memory
of the nodes.
The memory update,
it's implemented by
neural network,
typically a GRU,
a Recurrent Neural Network.
And then the updated states,
the data memory of the nodes
together with
the input information
associated with the mini batch
is used for providing node and
updating node embeddings.
Now the node
embedding function
is particularly
critical and is
based on
aggregating information
from the node neighbors.
Because this is justified by
the fact that in these graphs
and some nodes are often
infrequently updated.
Therefore, it is advantageous
to rely on
the connected neighbors
and information to compensate
for the information that is
lacking in up to
date information
that is missing for
specific nodes.
And this is the reason
why the node
embedding
update implementation
relies on, for example,
temporal graph
attention network
or temporal graph
sum networks.
Once the node
embedding has been
updated through this
type of processing,
the updated node
embeddings are fed,
are sent to a decoder which
provides node
classification or
link prediction in the case of
this block diagram.
The task is to
provide prediction
of the future for
future interactions.
This model had been
very successful,
improving by a large amount
the state of
the art in a number
of relevant tasks.
However, as we have
discussed before,
when when considering
dynamic graphs,
they have the issue
that for a large
batch size using
the aggregation
of a large number
of the temporal
events, there is
the possibility
that the later component
of the batch,
the later samples
lack the information
from the area
sample and have the not up to
date information
which can cause
stale update and
degrade the task
performance. We
have implemented
this model on
the IPU and the plot
on the left hand side of this
slide shows in fact
that the average
performance, the average test
precision during training,
it's much degraded for
larger bite size.
During training
increasing the number
of epochs the performance for
larger bite sizes
is significantly
worse than the one for bite
sizes small as
forty or sixty.
However, using batch sizes as
small as forty or
sixty typically
is connected with
a fine grained
computation that is not very
efficient on the conventional
hardware accelerators.
But implementing this type of
computation on
the IPOS is shown
here on the right hand side,
we have been able to maintain
improved task performance at
the same time delivering speed
up of training.
Maintaining a faster training
for the smaller batch size
corresponding to the case of
the large batch
size which doesn't
achieve the same
task performance.
In summary, we have reviewed
the main challenges of graph
neural network processing that
requires fast computation,
a heterogeneous and fragmented
computation with
a high memory load.
And we have discussed
the key features,
the key design
features of the IPU
architecture,
which can rely on
scalable and cost
effective DRAM
and can make use of the BXP
execution and the large amount
of and cheapest RAM to provide
efficient computation for fine
grained elements
associated with
the processing of graph
neural networks.
And we have
considered implementation
opportunities and methods for
training large
graphs on the IPO
and we have given
us a particular
example of efficient
fine grained
computation for a graph neural
network implemented
on the IPU.
And this concludes
the presentation.